[Música]
el mundo superó los 100 millones de
casos de contagio de kobe 19 eeuu
representa una cuarta parte del total de
estos casos con 25 millones de personas
contagiadas india para así el rusia y el
reino unido- figuran también entre los
países más afectados precisamente el
reino unido- se convirtió en el primer
país europeo con más de 100.000 víctimas
mortales
en el marco del foro económico virtual
de davos los líderes mundiales alzaron
su voz para exigir una distribución
equitativa de las vacunas contra el
joven 19 mientras la unión europea pide
a las farmacéuticas cumplir con los
tiempos de entrega los países más pobres
esperan mecanismos humanitarios que les
permita acceder a ellas
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden sostuvo su primera llamada con el
presidente de rusia vladimir putin los
mandatarios coincidieron en extender la
vigencia por cinco años más del tratado
nuevo start de armas nucleares también
la detención de naval y los ciberataques
y la lucha contra el kobe 19 fueron
otros de los temas que trataron
muy buenas noches estamos en vivo en las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález comenzamos con esta cifra
puntual el mundo superó los 100 millones
de casos de contagios de kobe 19 así lo
reporta el conteo de la universidad
johns hopkins eeuu india brasil rusia y
el reino unido son los países que
registran la mayor cantidad de casos de
coronavirus eeuu en particular
representa una cuarta parte del total de
estos casos con más de 25 millones de
personas contagiadas el coronavirus deja
hasta el momento más de 2.1 millones de
personas fallecidas en todo el planeta
esto mientras los países intentan
apresuradamente a poner en marcha sus
planes de vacunación y también las
farmacéuticas intentan cumplir bajo
presión con las entregas de las ventas
de las dosis de vacunas
en la jornada de hoy el reino unido-
como lo decíamos se convirtió en el
primer país europeo en superar las 100
mil personas fallecidas por cuenta del
coronavirus desde el gobierno liderado
por el primer ministro boris johnson
asumieron la responsabilidad por las
vidas perdidas debido a esta crisis
sanitaria el reino unido- contabiliza
3.7 millones de casos desde londres
louis ha podido nos dan más detalles
aunque la cifra de contagios diarios
sigue cayendo y de manera consecutiva
hoy el país registró un poco más de
20.000 nuevos casos 13.000 menos que
hace exactamente una semana la situación
sigue siendo muy delicada al menos 37
mil personas siguen hospitalizadas por
kobe hoy que el país alcanzó la muy
triste cifra de 100.000 personas muertas
por el código se preguntan los expertos
si está fallando la estrategia del
gobierno y además los tiempos en los que
adopta esta medida inicialmente en marzo
2020 cuando arrancó la pandemia
fuertemente aquí en el reino unido- los
expertos preveían proyectaban que habría
20.000 muertes
la estrategia dicen algunos está
fallando porque ha habido tres
confinamientos de hecho inglaterra está
en uno desde hace varias semanas las
fronteras siguen abiertas las
mascarillas no son obligatorias y no se
respeta la distancia social y las
autoridades hasta el momento
adoptando medidas más estrictas para
evitar que la población siga
interactuando tan cercanamente también
se asegura que las medidas se han
adoptado muy tarde el primer
confinamiento se decretó a partir del 23
de marzo de 2020 cuando algunos países
europeos habían adoptado esa misma
decisión varias semanas antes en el
marco del foro económico virtual de
davos algunos integrantes de la
comunidad internacional han alzado la
voz para reclamar una justa repartición
de las vacunas contra el jove y 19 está
desigual reparto de las vacunas pone en
riesgo la vida de millones de personas
marinas sardiña nos cuenta más en su
informe
la desigualdad mundial frente a la
emergencia de salud pública global
mientras los países ricos se aseguran
las dosis suficientes de las vacunas
contra el kobe 19 los más pobres
continúan con las manos vacías un
desigual reparto que este año ha
centrado las conversaciones en el foro
virtual de davos con mandatarios como el
sudafricano reclamando una justa
distribución del antídoto contra el
virus
los países ricos del mundo salieron y
adquirieron grandes dosis de vacunas de
los desarrolladores y fabricantes de
estas vacunas y algunos países incluso
han ido más allá y han adquirido hasta
cuatro veces más de lo que necesita su
población con el objetivo de acaparar
las vacunas
y ahora se está haciendo con la
exclusión de otros países que más las
necesitan
desde hace semanas la organización
mundial de la salud viene señalando la
necesidad de que la vacuna llegue a todo
el mundo no como una cuestión de caridad
sino como un beneficio global a largo
plazo y para ello la oms se puso en
marcha el plan internacional kóvacs con
la que busca hacer llegar la inyección a
más de 180 países pobres y de renta
media su llamado al que se unió la
canciller alemana afirmando que una
distribución equitativa es la única vía
para superar la pandemia es una elección
que queda aún más claro que antes que
tenemos que optar por un enfoque
multilateral que un enfoque de
autoaislamiento no resolverá nuestros
problemas lo vemos en primer lugar en la
cuestión de la vacunación ya que es la
vía de salida de la pandemia y aquí por
supuesto vemos la relación entre las
palabras y las acciones
el nacionalismo de las vacunas podría
generar un fuerte impacto en la economía
mundial
las billonarias según la cámara de
comercio internacional pero sobre todo
mientras la mayoría de la población
mundial no logre vacunarse seguirán en
juego millones de vidas cuando el mundo
supera los 10 millones de contagios
vemos un vistazo a cómo está avanzando
en américa los planes de vacunación por
lo menos en los 9 países del continente
que ya los han puesto en marcha eeuu
lidera con 23.5 millones de personas
inmunizadas le sigue canadá con más de
800.000 méxico es el país
latinoamericano que más vacunas ha
inoculado con más de 600.000 le sigue
costa rica y luego le sigue panamá en
américa del sur ecuador ha inoculado a
108 personas brasil a más de 800 mil
argentinas más de 300.000 y por último
chile ha vacunado a más de 64 mil
personas
en otros temas el presidente de estados
unidos joe biden sostuvo una llamada con
su homólogo ruso el presidente vladimir
putin con quien conversó sobre varios
temas de interés para ambos países
bardem expresó su preocupación por los
arrestos masivos de seguidores del líder
opositor alexéi navalni cuya captura
también fue condenada por los países del
g7 y le reclamó por las campañas masivas
de ciberataques que washington ha
culpado a rusia ambos mandatarios
acordaron trabajar en la extensión del
tratado nuevo start de control de armas
nucleares antes de que éste expire el
próximo mes de hecho ya el presidente
putin ordenó al parlamento de su país
que apruebe dicha extensión por cinco
años
biden y putin también acordaron una
lucha conjunta contra el cob el 19 y la
normalización de las relaciones
bilaterales así lo indicaban desde la
casa blanca en washington escuchemos
a otros ya que me da la oportunidad solo
les comunicaré que él llamó al
presidente putin esta tarde con la
intención de discutir nuestra
disposición para extender el nuevo
tratado start
por 5 años y también para reafirmar
nuestro sólido apoyo a la soberanía de
ucrania ante la continua agresión rusa y
también para hablar de temas que
preocupan como los ataques cibernéticos
a los de solarwinds las recompensas por
soldados estadounidenses en afganistán
la interferencia de la elección de 2020
el envenenamiento de alexéi navalni y el
trato hacia los manifestantes pacíficos
por parte de las fuerzas de seguridad
/ reuters
y de vuelta del 'viejo continente' el
primer ministro italiano giuseppe conte
presentó su renuncia formal al cargo
ante el presidente de ese país sergio
matar el a quien a su vez comenzó
consultas con los partidos políticos
para solucionar la crisis política en
ese país según los expertos conte
intenta que matar el aló convoque para
un nuevo mandato y éste pueda a su vez
conformar una nueva coalición de
gobierno
sin embargo conte no cuenta con nuevos
aliados por lo que muchos esperan que
matare la presente a otro candidato para
asumir el cargo de primer ministro y que
tenga este la capacidad de conformar un
nuevo gobierno
presidente de la república serio matar
el atributo cuesta matina el presidente
sergio matar ela se reunió esta mañana
en el palacio del quirinal con el primer
ministro el profesor giuseppe conté el
cual ha reseñado de dimisión y en
dimitió en nombre del gobierno del que
está a cargo y presidente de la
república y el presidente de la
república se reserva el derecho de
decidir qué hacer y pidió al gobierno
que se mantenga en el cargo de forma
interina le consulta las consultas con
los partidos políticos comenzarán mañana
miércoles 27 de enero por la tarde de
mayo es todo por el momento en las
noticias de france 24 ampliación de
estos y otros temas en france 24 punto
com en las redes sociales y también en
la app siga con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]